si quisiéramos escribir el nombre de
esta molécula y tratáramos de utilizar
el sistema assistance nos daríamos
cuenta rápidamente de que no podemos
utilizarlo porque para poder usar el
sistema assistance necesitamos que dos
de los grupos funcionales enlazados con
los carbonos de este enlace doble sean
idénticos y aquí en esta molécula
tenemos el enlace doble pero aquí
tenemos cuatro grupos distintos
enlazados con nuestro enlace doble
entonces tenemos que utilizar algún otro
sistema y vamos a utilizar el sistema
zeta ahora para utilizar el sistema zeta
tenemos que pensar en los números
atómicos para con ellos asignarle alguna
prioridad a los grupos enlazados con el
doble enlace así es que vamos a empezar
con este carbono y nos fijamos en los
átomos que están directamente enlazados
con ese carbono porque hoy por aquí
tenemos un hidrógeno enlazado
directamente y
en este lado tenemos un oxígeno y lo que
vamos a hacer es comparar el número
atómico de estos dos átomos y el que
tenga el número atómico más grande su
grupo va a tener más preferencia ok el
hidrógeno tiene un número atómico 1 y el
oxígeno tiene un número atómico 8 entre
más grande sea el número atómico mayor
va a ser la preferencia entonces el
grupo que tiene al oxígeno es el grupo
que tiene mayor prioridad
ok este grupo es el que tiene prioridad
número 1 y el hidrógeno es el de menor
prioridad que tiene prioridad 2 y ahora
vamos a fijarnos en el otro carbono nos
fijamos en los átomos que están
directamente enlazados con ese carbono
por aquí tenemos al bromo y de este lado
tenemos al carbono
entonces nos fijamos en los números
atómicos el carbono tiene un número
atómico 6
y el bromo tiene el número atómico 35 y
entre más grande sea el número atómico
mayor prioridad va a tener entonces el
bromo es el que más prioridad tiene y en
segundo lugar está este grupo y ya que
asignamos las prioridades a mí me gusta
poner por aquí una línea para que quede
muy claro cuáles son los dos lados del
enlace doble nos fijamos en los dos
grupos de mayor prioridad y si estos dos
grupos están en lados opuestos de la
línea del enlace doble entonces tenemos
una configuración
y esta es la tomamos de la palabra
alemana que quiere decir opuestos
ok porque los grupos de mayor prioridad
están en lados opuestos del doble enlace
y entonces lo ponemos a de opuestos en
alemán pero bueno ahora vamos con este
diagrama de puntos vamos a empezar con
este carbono de aquí tenemos aquí
hidrógeno y un oxígeno enlazados
directamente con este carbono ahora de
estos dos grupos este es el que tiene
mayor prioridad porque el oxígeno tiene
un mayor número atómico que el hidrógeno
lo que es lo mismo que teníamos por aquí
entonces ahora tenemos que ver este
carbono que está enlazado con otro
carbono y con un bromo y bueno esta
parte también es igualita a esta otra
pero están cambiados de lugar cierto
pero bueno el bromo tiene un mayor
número atómico entonces tiene mayor
prioridad y por lo tanto este grupo
metilo tiene menor prioridad y ahora
cuando dibujo la línea que pasa a lo
largo del doble enlace podemos observar
que los dos grupos de mayor prioridad
están del mismo lado del enlace doble y
esta es la configuración zeta de la
palabra alemana que significa juntos
porque están juntos del mismo lado
enlace doble que también podríamos
pensarlo como que están en el mismo lado
y escribir con faltas de ortografía y
todo pero escribir mismo
lado
y de esta forma tal vez nos acordemos
más cuál es la configuración z porque si
los dos grupos de mayor prioridad están
del mismo lado del mismo lado entonces
es una configuración zeta y bueno
estamos viendo este sistema ez porque es
un sistema mucho más inclusivo que el
sistema assistance porque para usar el
sistema systems necesitas que dos de los
grupos sean exactamente iguales y el
sistema ez se puede utilizar en
cualquier molécula por eso es mejor
utilizar el sistema ez para determinar
la configuración de los enlaces dobles
pero bueno vamos a ver otro ejemplo
ok
vamos a tomar este doble enlace y vamos
a asignarle una configuración ya sea o
se está empecemos por este carbono veo
aquí este carbono está enlazado con un
átomo de bromo y con un átomo de cloro
entonces para saber cuál tiene mayor
preferencia
buscamos sus números atómicos y el que
tenga el mayor número atómico ese es el
grupo de mayor preferencia y bueno el
bromo tiene un mayor número atómico por
lo cual tiene mayor preferencia
y ahora nos vamos con este otro carbono
nos fijamos en los átomos que están
directamente enlazados con él sabemos
que por aquí hay un carbono y por aquí
tenemos este otro carbono entonces
tenemos un empate porque obviamente
estos dos átomos de carbono tienen
exactamente el mismo número atómico y
para romper un empate lo que tenemos que
hacer es seguir adelante y lo que voy a
hacer
es volver a dibujar esta molécula
tenemos por aquí un doble enlace entre
dos carbonos este carbono tiene un
enlace con un promo y con un cloro y
este carbono está enlazado con dos
carbonos pero pues este carbono que es
este carbono tiene un doble enlace con
este oxígeno y solo con el propósito de
determinar cuál de los dos grupos tiene
mayor prioridad y para simplificar las
cosas vamos a pretender que este doble
enlace en realidad son dos enlaces con
oxígenos aunque esto es solo para que
sea más fácil determinar cuál de los dos
grupos tiene mayor prioridad porque pues
un enlace doble con un oxígeno para
estas cosas de las prioridades de los
grupos cuenta como dos enlaces con
oxígenos pero bueno este carbono tiene
otro enlace con un hidrógeno hidrógeno y
por otro lado el otro carbono
este carbono de aquí tiene un enlace con
dos hidrógenos pero que no hidrógeno y
un enlace con un oxígeno oxígeno y este
oxígeno está enlazado con otro hidrógeno
y ahora regresamos otra vez a pensar en
eso de las prioridades estamos viendo
cuál de los dos grupos enlazados con
este carbono tiene mayor prioridad ahora
este carbono está enlazado con estos dos
carbonos y aquí tenemos un empate porque
los dos carbonos tienen el mismo número
atómico y entonces tenemos que pensar en
los átomos que están enlazados
directamente con estos otros dos
carbonos del empate aunque este carbono
está enlazado directamente con oxígeno
oxígeno e hidrógeno
entonces escribimos por aquí oxígeno
oxígeno hidrógeno y por acá este carbono
está enlazado con un oxígeno
con dos hidrógenos entonces escribimos
oxígeno hidrógeno hidrógeno y para
asignarle prioridad a alguno de estos
dos grupos nos fijamos en el primer
punto de diferencia entre estos dos así
es que empezamos por aquí tenemos dos
oxígenos así es que seguimos empatados y
entonces nos vamos al siguiente átomo y
tenemos un oxígeno contra un hidrógeno y
aquí se rompe el empate porque el
oxígeno claramente tiene un número
atómico más grande entonces este es
nuestro primer punto de diferencia aquí
se rompe el empate y este grupo o sea
este grupo es el que tiene mayor
prioridad
este grupo tiene la prioridad número uno
y este grupo tiene la prioridad número 2
y entonces nada más nos falta poner una
línea paralela al enlace doble
y listo buscamos los dos grupos de mayor
prioridad y podemos observar que están
del mismo lado de la línea aunque están
del mismo lado del doble enlace así es
que tenemos una configuración zeta y
bueno vamos a ver otro ejemplo
aunque y ahora tal vez podríamos
preguntarnos cómo se incorpora el
sistema ez a la nomenclatura iupac y
bueno eso es justo lo que vamos a hacer
ahorita digamos que tenemos por aquí
esta molécula y que le queremos poner un
nombre entonces lo primero que hacemos
es buscar la cadena de carbonos más
larga que contenga al enlace doble
aunque eso sería esta cadena y numerar
los carbonos de esa cadena de tal forma
que los sustituye entes tengan el menor
número posible lo que hay entonces
tenemos que empezar por aquí este es el
carbono 1 2 3 4 5 6
y 7 así es que tenemos una cadena de 7
carbonos con un enlace doble eso cómo se
llama pues se llama este no
no ahora tenemos este doble enlace y
empieza en el carbono número 3 entonces
tenemos que poner por aquí 3 eterno
después nos ponemos a pensar en los
sustituye entes que salen de la cadena
por aquí tenemos un grupo metilo y por
aquí tenemos un grupo de tilos ahora a
la hora de agregarlos al nombre
tenemos que ordenarlos alfabéticamente y
pues la betty viene antes en el
abecedario que la m de metil entonces
escribimos 4x
2 metil
es útil 3 obtener y también hay que
notar que esta es la forma de antigua de
nombrar a esta molécula actualmente
también se le llama 4 etil 2 metil etil
efe 3 1
y cualquiera de estas dos formas son
válidas pero bueno acaba de llegar el
momento de ponernos a pensar en este
enlace doble y su configuración lo que
hay tiene una configuración
o tiene una configuración zeta y bueno
vamos a empezar con este carbono de aquí
que sabemos que tiene un hidrógeno por
acá
así es que queremos saber cuál de estos
dos grupos tiene mayor prioridad por
aquí este carbono está enlazado
directamente con este hidrógeno y con
este carbono de aquí ahora sabemos que
el carbono tiene un mayor número atómico
que el hidrógeno entonces este es el
grupo con mayor prioridad y este
hidrógeno tiene menor prioridad entonces
es hora de analizar al otro carbono
ok nos fijamos en los átomos que están
enlazados directamente con este carbono
tenemos aquí un carbono y por aquí
tenemos otro carbono entonces tenemos un
empate
y para que sea un poco más sencillo
averiguar cuál de estos dos grupos tiene
mayor prioridad pues vamos a volver a
dibujar la molécula por acá o bueno una
parte de ella tenemos por aquí este
carbono este de aquí que tiene un enlace
doble con este carbono este carbono está
enlazado con un hidrógeno y con otro
carbono que ya vimos que tiene mayor
prioridad pero sólo vamos a dibujar esta
parte de la molécula y de este lado del
doble enlace este carbono tiene un
carbono para acá que tiene dos
hidrógenos y luego otro carbono que
tiene tres hidrógenos ok y luego de este
otro lado este carbono está enlazado con
un carbono que tiene dos hidrógenos y
otro carbono que tiene otros dos
hidrógenos y otro enlace con otro
carbono que tiene
tres hidrógenos ok y ahora simplemente
tenemos que averiguar cuál de estos dos
grupos tiene mayor prioridad así es que
empezamos con este carbono nos fijamos
en los átomos directamente enlazados con
él tenemos un empate porque ambos son un
carbono entonces tenemos que seguir
viendo y nos fijamos en este carbono que
está enlazado con un carbono un
hidrógeno y un hidrógeno y lo escribimos
por aquí tenemos carbono hidrógeno
hidrógeno y lo comparamos con lo que
pasa con este otro carbono que está
enlazado con un carbono y dos hidrógenos
entonces tenemos carbono hidrógeno
hidrógeno aunque yo estamos buscando por
el primer punto de diferencia pero
todavía no llegamos lo que hay porque
tenemos carbono contra carbono hidrógeno
contra hidrógeno e hidrógeno contra
hidrógeno así es que seguimos teniendo
un empate y todavía no sabemos cuál de
los dos grupos tiene mayor prioridad
por lo que tenemos que seguir adelante
ahora nos vamos a fijar en los átomos
enlazados con estos carbonos que son los
siguientes en la línea empezamos con
este carbono que está enlazado con un
carbono hidrógeno hidrógeno
ok carbono hidrógeno hidrógeno y vamos
con el otro carbono que está enlazado
con hidrógeno hidrógeno hidrógeno ok
hidrógeno hidrógeno hidrógeno y ahora si
finalmente tenemos nuestro primer punto
de diferencia entre estos dos grupos
porque ya estamos comparando un carbono
con un hidrógeno y el carbono tiene un
mayor número atómico que el hidrógeno
entonces este grupo tiene mayor
prioridad ok eso significa que este
grupo tiene mayor prioridad
y ese grupo por acá es este grupo de
aquí
este es el grupo con mayor prioridad y
este grupo estilo tiene menor prioridad
finalmente dibujamos esta línea y como
podemos observar los dos grupos de mayor
prioridad se encuentran en lados
opuestos de la línea en lados opuestos
del enlace doble así es que esta es una
configuración en la que la configuración
de este enlace doble es el y lo que
hacemos para integrarlo a la
nomenclatura iupac es ir al inicio del
nombre y poner entre paréntesis la letra
e ok entonces el nombre de esta molécula
es e4 steel 2 metil 3 obsceno o también
lo podemos llamar e4 steel 2 metil f 3 1